Euh, salut à toutes et à tous,
euh. Aujourd'hui, on est en assemblée générale euh
du npa jeune à Paris.
On fait cette vidéo pour vous appeler, euh. En fait, euh.
À soutenir financièrement le npa et le npa jeune,
parce que, euh.
Donc, on est de toutes les luttes,
on est de tous les combats,
on va continuer à s'exprimer euh.
Pour la jeunesse et pour le monde du travail,
on va continuer à intervenir euh.
Dans toutes les manifes, surtout nos lieux d'études,
surtout nos lieux de travail.
Mais. Et euh, tout ça, malheureusement,
ça coûte de l'argent.
Et euh, comme vous vous en doutez,
on n'est pas financé euh.
Par euh le grand patronat et par euh.
Les milliardaires français.
Par conséquent, euh,
tous nos fonds, en fait,
ils reposent uniquement sur des dons,
euh. Des dons de sympathisant, de militant,
euh de gens en fait, qui soutiennent ce qu'on défend,
qui soutiennent notre position
communique, internationaliste et révolutionnaire.
Si vous voulez faire vivre ces combats,
si vous voulez faire vivre le npa et le npa jeune,
n'hésitez pas à s'inscrire. Voilà, merci à vous.